alexis poulain alexis blanc alors votre
réaction
après ces quelques nouvelles mesures pas
vraiment dit nous ait pas de nouvelles
mesures non des choses qu'on connaissait
déjà
bon j'étais cours parce qu'il n'y avait
pas beaucoup d'annoncés les deux seules
choses c'est de voir qu'il va y avoir
plus de tests des circuits courts 1 pour
ceux qui doivent certes éthiques sont
symptomatiques une quarantaine qui passe
à sept jours et puis détente de tests
qu'on attendait dans certaines villes
avec des points très rouge sur la carte
c'est marseille bordeaux la guadeloupe
et à une règlement au cas par cas de
l'évolution de ce virus sur la carte
mais encore une allocution pour ne pas
dire grand chose on savait toutes les
choses là que les personnes âgées sont
les plus darif que le virus circule
beaucoup il ya 42 territoires
départements qui sont rouges et jean
castex a rappelé qu'il fallait te laver
les mains il a aussi annoncé qu'il
fallait qu'il allait renforcer des
circuits a dédié pour les personnes
prioritaires pour les personnes testées
positives 2000 recrutement au sein de
l'assurance maladie et des ars pour
effectuer le traçage et puis vous l'avez
donc évoqué l'instant la durée
d'isolement ramené à 7 jours avec des
contrôles qui seront effectuées oui des
contrôles sans doute par les agents de
tractage qui vont voir qui les familles
respecte la quarantaine de sept jours
une fois qu'un cas positif a été déclaré
dans la famille le problème évidemment
c'est la fiabilité de ces tests la
rapide piste et est jean castex a eu son
test et au résultat en moins d'une heure
évidemment il est le premier ministre
pour les autres c'est plus compliqué
alors on espère que ces mesures là vont
permettre de faire des tests et vient de
recruter des gens à la rs et on est déjà
très fort puisque la france est le
troisième pays européen qui tu es ce que
plus l'on combiné avec un million de
tests par semaine donc on est on est
dans les clous mais encore une fois
c'est est la fête c'est bien maintenant
quelles sont les mesures par exemple
quand un enfant va être testé positif
pour l'école pour la garde de cet enfant
à domicile pour les parents comment tout
ça va se passer tout ça ne sont des
questions qui restent en suspens on nous
avait dit pourtant pendant l'été un que
ce soit jean castex sous jean michel
bancaire que le gouvernement était prêt
pour cette rentrée
doublement pas du tout puisque on voit
bien que ça tarde encore à savoir
quelles vont être les mesures au delà
des tests au delà des cas contact est ce
que les classes vont rester ouvertes
aujourd'hui des cas avérés sont un peu
partout sur le territoire
c'était attendu les français ne sont pas
stupides ils savaient que la rentrée
mettre tous ces enfants dans des classes
retourner à dans les métropoles prendre
les transports en commun ça allait faire
que l'écho de l'épidémie allait
reprendre le problème c'est qu'elle
qu'elle est encore une fois la réponse
du gouvernement alors qu'une fois ci
c'est les tests
reste à savoir qui se traîne réponse
efficace alors vous l'avez rappelé pas
de réelles mesures drastiques pour cette
courte allocution plus tôt un appel à la
responsabilisation collective un mot
peut-être du ton employé par jean castex
ont haussé le ton jean castex un peu
paternaliste un peu calmé essayer de le
rassurer pas faire du sensationnalisme
surtout pas être toujours rappeler à
cette approche territoriale des
problèmes dire que paris n'a pas la
solution heureusement d'ailleurs
heureusement encore une fois aussi qu'il
n'y a pas de mesures de confinement
programmés ou bien de couvre-feu de
choses comme ça parce que les
commerçants ont beaucoup souffert cet
été et remettre ça maintenant aurait été
encore un coup fatal je crois que sans
vouloir le dire mais c'est en filigrane
le gouvernement jongle pour à la
préserver la santé des centaines et
essayer de maintenir l'économie sous
perfusion sachant que le plan de relance
de risque de n'être pas suffisant compte
tenu de la chute de croissance et le
pays dès qu'on a eu donc le groupe
problème et la grande majorité du
problème aujourd'hui du gouvernement
c'est la sauvegarde de l'emploi c'est
l'activité
et c'est bien sûr la santé des français
mais une quarantaine à sept jours c'est
bien évidemment peut-être que le virus
est moins virulent je ne sais pas
pourquoi on est passé de 14 à 7
comment ça va se faire d'autres
questions aussi sur la façon dont on va
gérer les frontières et les aéroports
là dessus pas vraiment de réponse donc
une allocution vraiment pour occuper
l'espace médiatique pour dire que le
gouvernement avait affronté de défense
et que je crois qu'il gère comme il peut
et bien des contradictions entre
l'activité économique la santé est ce
qu'il est possible de faire et la
connaissance sur ce virus
parce qu'encore une fois beaucoup de
jeunes à 7
picou symptomatique bien sûr des des
personnes plus vulnérables qui elles
sont taris et qu'on doit protéger de
manière communautaire
donc voilà l'équation difficile à
laquelle essaye de répondre le
gouvernement avec une communication qui
semble un peu en deçà ou au loin de ce
qu'on peut attendre compte tenu de de la
crise qui était une guerre rappelez vous
il ya quelques mois un tout dernier
moment rapidement alexis poulain le
conseil scientifique qui conseille le
gouvernement sur la gestion de
l'épidémie s'est montré inquiet ces
derniers jours on l'a entendu là il
appelait à prendre des mesures
difficiles est ce que vous avez le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'emmanuel macro
jean castex s émancipent de ce conseil
scientifique est ce que c'est la
politique qui reprend la main sur
scientifique
oui c'est clairement la politique qui
reprend la main sur le scientifique le
pragmatisme économique aussi comme je
vous le disais je crois que gouvernement
on ne veut pas être responsable de la
faillite d'un pays et que aujourd'hui
les connaissances sur le virus avant ce
qu'on a le peut-être un vaccin qui va
arriver dans les mois qui viennent et
que les esb arrière ont été intégrés par
la plupart des français vous avez vu
dans la rue les gens respectent les
règles qui sont pourtant parfois lui f
eh bien les français aux listes sont
très conscients de leurs responsabilités
personnelles telles que t'as rien de
leur dire qu'ils sont stupides ou qui ne
comprennent rien ils ont très bien
compris il faut qu'ils peuvent pour
enrayer l'épidémie à leur niveau mais
ils ont aussi une vie la vie doit
continuer et le choix du politique
heureusement que nous ne rentrons pas
dans une dictature sanitaire des plutôt
souhaitable
merci beaucoup alexis pour l'un pour
votre réaction après donc cette courte
déclaration du premier ministre à jean
castex